the conflict in ukraine has pushed gas
prices to more than five dollars a
gallon in parts of the u.s food prices
are rising at the fastest pace in years
and housing costs are rising by as much
as 30 percent everywhere you look there
are signs that inflation is not going
away the federal reserve has said it
plans to raise u.s interest rates to
slow inflation but that cure has a cost
the last time inflation was this high
the fed raised rates by so much that it
put the country into a recession will we
see a repeat of that today i'm going to
explain how the fed could take the u.s
into a recession
why that could be a good thing and why
the fed's next steps are so important to
our economy's future
let's get into it the federal reserve
was created to provide price stability
for the united states
that means controlling inflation is its
first and primary goal even though fed
leaders have said they expect to raise
interest rates multiple times this year
there is concern that the fed is already
too far behind that's because once
consumers and businesses begin to expect
prices to rise consistently they change
their behavior accordingly economists
are worried that this shift has already
happened and that even after supply
chain bottlenecks and labor shortage
issues are resolved inflation
expectations will remain high that would
cause businesses to keep raising their
prices and workers to continue to demand
higher wages what's been shown to rain
in spiraling price increases
historically is higher interest rates
higher rates make consumers want to save
rather than spend and businesses hold
off on expanding that pullback can slow
the economy down which also slows down
the rate at which prices are increasing
but if inflation remains stubbornly high
the fed may have to raise rates so much
that the economy stops growing
altogether and starts shrinking when
that happens jobs are lost wages fall
and the stock market generally turns red
this sounds bad and it is but economists
generally agree that it's better than
the alternative which is allowing prices
to continue rising at a fast pace that's
because inflation unchecked increases to
the point that a country's currency
loses so much value that it becomes
virtually worthless we've seen this
happen in places like germany and
zimbabwe and more recently in venezuela
the cost for everything jumps companies
can't buy materials or basic supplies
and workers lose their jobs when we last
saw inflation as high as it is now then
fed chairman paul volcker had interest
rates set at more than 14
and that was down from 19 just a few
months earlier that eventually ground
inflation back to a more manageable
level but it also brought about a
painful recession tanked the stock
market and sent u.s consumer sentiment
to its lowest point on record the
question many in the market are starting
to ask themselves is
will fed chair jerome powell be willing
to do the same thing today if necessary
there are worries that the answer is no
because of what we've seen from the
chairman in recent history powell said
for about a year that the current
inflation we're seeing would be
transitory and would recede on its own
before retiring the term in november and
committing to take action investors also
remember how powell reversed course on
raising interest rates in 2019 after the
stock market started to buckle interest
rates had reached just under 2.5 percent
at that point having been near zero for
more than a decade then there was the
unprecedented action pal and the fed
took in march 2020 that sent stocks
soaring even as the u.s economy had its
worst quarter in history that gave some
like alliance chief economic adviser
muhammad al-arian the impression that
this fed was doing more for the market
than the real economy so many are
watching every word from pow in the fed
to see if the policy makers there are
committed to doing whatever it takes to
tame inflation the fed will have to walk
a tightrope going forward if inflation
does ultimately cool later in the year
as they are again predicting raising
rates too fast could cause a recession
unnecessarily but if they raise rates
too slowly inflation could spike and get
out of control causing even greater pain
with so much uncertainty in the world
the only thing we know for sure is that
policymakers will need to be on their
a-game
if you enjoyed this video i want you to
hit that like button and subscribe to
keep up with my latest videos on markets
i want you to be like yo gotti who told
us in 2020 i'm a real hustler i'm
recession proof i know how to make the
paper and stack it too i'll see you next
time
you